we've seen government debt
explode we've seen living standards
collapse for all no working people at
the same time the biggest and fastest
ever increase in the wealth of
millionaires and
billionaires nobody's connecting these
two things the reality is we've created
a world which tells you you need to be
rich to be happy you need to be rich to
be of value and yet which simultaneously
makes it almost impossible for them to
get
rich listen don't buy don't buy the hype
on it you know yeah work hard to take
care of your
family and be proud of yourself be proud
of the things that you achieve because
they're selling you a dream that they
never gave you a chance to get in and
and if you buy that dream you're going
to be unhappy and I've Got Friends that
work really really hard and struggled to
pay the bills and I want I want those
people to be proud cuz that was my dad
and my mom